Dylan Movaney has no idea what girlhood is.
Girlhood is spending the entire summer you turn 13
crying and trying to figure out why you feel like a little girl
and a grown woman at the same time.
It's always having a sweater on hand in high school,
just in case you need it to tie around your waist
so nobody will see blood on your pants.
Finding yourself as a teenager
feeling both awkwardly sexualized and not sexy enough
somehow at the same time.
It's spending hours on your knees
praying that your body will be able to get pregnant,
and then falling back down on your knees
feeling devastated and like a failure.
Your body loses a baby you desperately wanted.
It's worrying about endometriosis,
ovarian cancer,
yearly mammograms,
pelvic exams, ectopic pregnancies,
birth control, and postpartum depression.
It's being afraid to walk alone at night.
It's dedicating your body to the growth,
development, and nutrition of a new human being
that is completely dependent and reliant on you.
And using your body to play a major role
in keeping the human population alive.
And still feeling like it isn't good enough,
it isn't skinny enough,
it isn't perfect enough.
It's watching your little babies grow
from fetuses to infants to toddlers
to children to teenagers and into adulthood.
Feeling your heart swell with joy at watching them grow
and heartbreak at the same time because it means they need you less.
It's going through the long and Slow process of menopause
and watching as your body and your mind drastically change
all back over again,
almost the way they did when you were 13.
And, of course,
it's being expected to sit back and quietly watch
as males dress up like you,
as they mimic you,
as they mock you,
and as they get brand deals and millions of dollars for doing so.
It's wonderful.
It's difficult,
it's heartbreaking,
it's exciting,
it's fun. And it's very deep.
So deep, in fact,
that it is intertwined in your very DNA.
And it is something that can never,
ever be purchased nor surgically manufactured.